as Congress returns to Washington  Democrats on the House Judiciary are  expected to significantly expand their  impeachment inquiry into President Trump  they plan to include the president's  possible role in hush money payments to  women who say they had affairs with mr.  Trump which he denies and Democrats want  to scrutinize reports that he offered  pardons to officials willing to break  the law over immigration policies  Democrats also want to know whether the  president's resorts and properties have  profited from government business the  Air Force says it is reviewing reports  over the weekend that Cruz occasionally  stayed at the president's Turnberry golf  course or sari resort in Scotland